i am of course like many other people
sad to see him though
uh but i think it was a very bold move
when i saw it
i was
like
you know
dumbfounded i wanted
to see
if it is better to have loved and lost
than never to have loved at all
john
oh god
oh god john oh
johnny
the big secret is out
what was your reaction when you first
learned that big would be passing in the
very first episode of and just like that
you know i am of course like many other
people sad to see you though
but i think it was a very bold move and
i think
you know the title of the show is end
just like that and
it's open to interpretation but to me
that means
in a moment
your life can be transformed something
wonderful can happen something
horrifying can happen
and certainly there could be no more
uh
kind of
a blow to the center of carrie and her
life than than robbing her of mr big and
so
i just think it was i think it was very
bold and i think it starts the
it
it it starts the new series out on on
such a foot that you you you see we're
not going to be treading water we're
actually going to be sailing into
completely unchartered waters and we
hope you come with us the way you did
the last time i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
charlotte he had a heart attack
i know i know but if you hadn't been at
the concert you would have been with him
and you would have he would have done
something and then he would be alive now
what was it like for you when you first
learned the news what was your first
reaction to michael patrick king taking
the show that way and also your reaction
to that scene like were you on set when
sarah jessica parker and chris know
filmed that
no i was not on set no
i was very nervously sitting at home
wondering how it was going
um
i when when michael patrick told me this
which was quite some time ago um
i was i was nervous i was sad of course
i love chris thankfully he's fine but
you know it's hard because you
you never really want this to happen in
life just like you don't want it to
happen in in in fictional life but on
the other hand it is actually
something that does happen in life so
from that perspective i did feel
i did i could see the
possibilities of
of trying to deal with that and you know
we are still a comedy but we have always
dealt with with serious things and i
knew
that sarah felt very strongly about it
and i wanted
them to to you know it was a bold it was
a bold vision you know um and very very
terrifying of course and i mean i was so
worried and i mean i don't want to put
words in his mouth but the first thing
he said to me was like i felt terrible i
had to make them do it over and over
again i felt so bad i mean and when i
saw it
i was
like
you know
dumbfounded i just thought it was so
beautifully done
so beautifully done and such great
acting from both of them
um you know i'm not gonna cry but i
could because you know i am charlotte
but you know it i think it's it's
beautiful and i understand that people
are are having a lot of feelings
gary everything is just beautiful
the funeral director asked me if i
wanted to rent a coffin
you know since he's being cremated right
big would never want to be in a rental
he wouldn't even rent a car you got to
tell me whose idea was it for big to
pass and why was it important for this
new series
it was mine
because i wanted
to see
if it is better to have loved and lost
than never to have loved at all
and i wanted to do an amazing uh
arc of for carrie and sarah jessica
because i knew she could be amazing
playing both the dark and the light i
wanted everyone to see that and i wanted
to write for that
but really
also the thesis of the show has always
been and kerry says it in the finale
voiceover of the last series everybody
thinks it's about mr big calling and
saying i'm coming but really what the
voiceover is
the most significant challenging
relationship of all is the one you have
with yourself
and if you have that and then somebody
else comes along well that's fabulous so
this is now
the significant challenging relationship
of her life
is the one she'll have with herself and
others we'll see and then the friends
the other thing is you know these
friends these three friends to me
they're so solid and they're so golden
and then i thought
the
friendships really show up in the hard
times and i i really wanted to see what
happens when your friends show up for
you in the most difficult thing that can
happen to you in life which is a death
it's very real we all experience loss
and i i love that you took the show
there truly but of course the fans are
already having some big reactions hey
lauren let me tell you the fans had some
big reactions when aiden left
so we're right on brand there was a
whole war
about the fact that aiden moved on and i
just want to remind the fans i love you
chris knoth is not dead
chris knoth is right across town
somewhere doing a zoom he's fine this i
love that people are upset it means they
care they felt loss which is what's a
it's fiction so it's fun to feel
sad if it's not real it's fun to to feel
pain if it's not on if it's fortunately
not your pain fictional pain is
what art's for it helps us get through
real life sometimes agreed well peloton
has released a statement and their stock
has taken a dip
did you expect this big of a reaction
um first of all
no okay
i mean look the reality is
peloton's in the show
because i wanted to show that big was
current
was healthy and alive and current and
the the most current thing that i know
about everybody right now including
myself is we're on the pelotons our show
has always reflected what's hot in the
world whether it be manolo blahniks or
pelotons in biggs case so he's on a
peloton because that's the premium bike
for home exercise
that's the gucci of home exercise that's
what mr big would have
and he's on that bike and he did not
have the best that's why it's in the
show it reflects reality of his reality
[Music]
you